a royal tour intended to promote the
platinum jubilee
but for some it served as a reminder of
a painful colonial past
and as far as the president of guyana is
concerned it's time to say sorry
i think
an apology is needed
this was
one of the greatest atrocities
in human history
and those who suffered
in this atrocity are persons from the
region a lot of persons from the
caribbean region
and that suffering was not only immense
it was generational
and
and a lot of wealth was derived from the
suffering a lot of benefits was derived
from the suffering
the slave trade was once backed by both
parliament and the royal family until it
was abolished in the 1830s
what was once the empire became the
commonwealth and just last month its
future king addressed the sins of his
family's past
but was criticized for falling short of
an apology
i want to express my profound sorrow
slavery was abhorrent
and it should never have happened
the royal tours were intended to
strengthen the links between the uk and
the caribbean
but it seems they may have weakened them
with many announcing plans to become a
republic before calling for compensation
guyana made this move in the 70s and say
sometimes a reset is needed
it is not cutting links
it is
renewing yourself
on this new path that uh understands the
history what are saying now listen
we are on our own uh our own path uh
and in this part we are equals and we
are going to
strengthen our relationship with you but
you know this is the way we're going to
advance
the royals and the brits in general are
still highly regarded across the
caribbean
but it's clear that there is a momentum
for real change and the caribbean are no
longer asking for it it's being demanded
shimane freeman powell sky news